on passe à notre second débat vous le
savez c'est notre choix il est
volontairement décalée de l'actualité on
ne court pas après le buzz du jour dans
cette émission l'abstention au programme
ce soir alors que deux fondations
viennent de rendre un rapport sur ce
thème après le record malheureusement
record historique aux dernières
élections régionales deux électeurs sur
trois ne s'étaient pas déplacés mathias
arese
historiquement l'élection présidentielle
a toujours été le scrutin préféré des
français jusqu'à présent épargnée par
une abstention croissante dans la
majorité des scrutins on observe depuis
bientôt quinze ans une tendance à la
hausse à l'heure d'élire le président de
la république face au phénomène
plusieurs acteurs de la vie politique la
fondation jean jaurès et le think tank
fondapol avance des pistes de réflexion
abc le droit de vote à 16 ans aller à la
rencontre des électeurs avec le vote
mobiles ou encore proposer le vote par
internet ou par correspondance éric
kerrouche sénateur socialiste des landes
a déjà défendu le vote par
correspondance et devrait prochainement
porter une proposition de droit de vote
à 16 ans tout ce qui peut améliorer les
conditions techniques du vol j'ai suis
favorable j'ai un petit bémol avec le
vote électronique parce que là encore
une fois quand on regarde les études
disponibles on se rend compte que
techniquement il n'y a aucune façon de
le sécuriser de manière d il ya plein de
modalités qu'on peut imaginer qu'ils
pourraient être utilisés autre point
évoqué celui d'une re mobilisation
citoyenne pour le président de la
commission des lois au sénat françois
noël buffet cela passera par une
amélioration du débat politique
et puis je crois que la deuxième piste
la plus importante c'est celle de ré
intéresser les français à la politique
celle d'avoir des débats de bon niveau
des débatteurs de bon niveau et d'être
trouvé la capacité à pouvoir convaincre
nos concitoyens que le vote est non
seulement essentiel fondamental une
démocratie mais que le débat doit être
intéressant dès que quelqu'un élève le
débat dès que quelqu'un élèves le le les
niveau d'idées
ça marche dernière piste envisagée
rendre le vote obligatoire comme cela
est déjà le cas en belgique au brésil
pour l'heure aucune famille politique ni
est favorable
l'abstention le symptôme d'une
démocratie malade voilà le thème de
notre débat je vous présente mes invités
c'est une braconniers bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes professeur de sciences
politiques directrice de sciences po
saint germain en laye spécialise de
l'abstention votre dernier livre c'est
les inaudible avec nos âmes et hier
c'est aux presses de sciences po
dominique reynié bonsoir le directeur
général de la fondation pour
l'innovation politique
professeur à sciences po dernière par
réduction de la fondapol 2022 le risque
populiste en france vague 5 jerry
pelletier bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
directeur des études de la fondation
jean jaurès est votre dernier livre
c'est la fête est finie aux édition de
l'observatoire et lætitia krupa est
toujours à mes côtés évidemment vos deux
fondations donc rendu un rapport sur sur
l'abstention disait après une commande
de l'assemblée qui faisait suite à ce
désintérêt historique lors des
régionales rappelle le chiffre de
l'abstention au premier tour
66,72 % dominique reynié doudou vient
t-il si on fait une analyse un peu
général ce désintérêt des français
de nombreux facteurs
ça vient d'eux du sentiment que voter
n'a pas l'utilité
qu'on espérait
cela vient pour certains d'une forme de
désintégration sociale afin de mise à
l'écart ça vient d'une absence de
de compétences et de connaissances à
part ce que parce qu'on n'a pas été
maintenu dans un niveau d'information
suffisant ça vient de déceptions
politiques
ça vient d'eux des alternances et qui
ont qui se sont succédé qui ont pu
donner le sentiment que tous les mêmes
un élément qu'on peut qu'on peut trouver
souvent et puis et beaucoup d abord il
ya aussi le fait pas dans la cinquième
vague qu'on a mesurée récemment auprès
de 3000 personnes de l'échantillon parce
que cet échantillon qui est solide on a
interrogé sur les raisons pour
lesquelles on pourrait s'abstenir en
2022 et on voit que la dimension
protestataires est très forte c'est à
dire sous le sous le sou l'énoncé
suivant
je n'irai pas voter parce que ce sont
tous les mêmes je n'irai pas voter parce
que de toute façon les femmes les hommes
politiques ne tiennent pas compte de ce
que nous leur disons toute une série
d'annoncés de ce type en fait réunissent
la plus grande part des ddd des
électeurs interrogés lorsqu'il faut
donner une justification à leur
abstention et en même temps on peut dire
c'est déjà une discussion qu'il faudrait
pousser mais en même temps on pourrait
dire c'est une façon d'un oubli un peu
sur l'abstention que de dire par là je
proteste mais il ya certainement un fond
de vérité jerry pelletier dans le
rapport de votre fondation vous avez
travaillé sur une autre qui est intitulé
la france qui s'en fout c'est les
bataillons de la france qui s'en fout
sont de plus en plus nombreux bah ouais
je crois que dans les phénomènes aussi
qui peuvent expliquer l'abstention il ya
évidemment eu ce qu'on appelle
l'individualisation de la société ou si
vous avez un journaliste qui s'appelle
vincent coq berck a parlé de la
civilisation du cocon une civilisation
du cocon c'est une société un peuple
d'une façon générale qui a tendance à se
recroqueviller sur sa sphère intime sur
sa sphère personnelle et qui par
définition un rapport au collectif qui
est extrêmement d'élite et qui est
extrêmement abîmées or le vote par
définition il a une dimension collective
et donc effectivement je pense que
l'individuation de la société d'une
façon générale entraîne aussi une
apathie une apathie e existentiel d'une
façon final et une apathie démocratique
quand demandez aux français dans les
grandes enquêtes s'ils ont le sentiment
ou non d'appartenir à une communauté que
ce soit une communauté religieuse une
communauté culturelle où la communauté
nationale vous avez un français sur deux
qui dit non j'ai pas le sentiment
d'appartenir à une communauté donc dans
cette époque effectivement
individualiste où il ya un rapport au
civisme qui à mon sens est très haut
déliter ou pour se faire vacciner le
resort civique ne fonctionne pas et on
est obligé d'utiliser des arguments de
la société des loisirs si vous faites
pas vacciner vous finirez par otéra
devenir est pas au cinéma vous n'aurez
pas dans les bars alors que pendant six
mois on leur avait dit faites vous
vacciner parce que c'est pour autrui
c'est pour les gens plus faible que vous
le resort civique ne fonctionnait pas le
ressort consommation et société de
loisirs fonctionner et donc
effectivement ça a des impacts aussi sur
le vote et les citoyens consommateurs
n'achètent plus le produit qu'on leur
vend ouais c'est une braconniers vous
aviez publié presque quinze ans je
passais de 2007 un livre intitulé la
démocratie de l'abstention
quand on regarde les chiffres la
situation elle s'est aggravée depuis
elle s'est aggravée dans le sens où
aujourd'hui il ya très peu de scrutin au
cours desquelles on enregistre plus de
votes que d'abstention donc c'est la
définition qu'on avait donné des
démocratie de l'abstention c'est c'est
un pays dans lequel pour la plupart des
scrutins voilà il ya plus de gens qui ne
votent pas que des gens qui se déplacent
de la lésion donc ça s'est aggravé pour
toutes les élections intermédiaires avec
une une amplification dont une partie
est sans doute dû évidemment à la crise
sanitaire mais j'ai envie de tempérer un
peu ce que je viens d'entendre puisqu'on
a quand même 90 % des inscrits sur les
listes électorales qui pouvait aisément
participé au dernier à la dernière
présidentielle qui l'ont fait donc je
crois que le mot le plus adapté pour
parler de la participation électorale
depuis une vingtaine d'années c'est
l'intermittence c'est le phénomène le
plus
évident pour pour parler de l'évolution
que nous enregistrons
les gens n'ont pas cessé de voter n'y a
pas de rupture avec le vote n'y a pas de
rejet de la démocratie représentative
il ya simplement une relation plus
intermittentes par par intermittence de
plus en plus de personnes et notamment
les jeunes votent uniquement à
l'élection présidentielle et c'est pas
du tout la même chose ça renvoie pas au
même rapport aux institutions parce que
ces mêmes citoyens qui vous disent je
n'irai plus tous les mêmes entre deux
présidentielle voulait retrouver en tout
cas jusqu'à aujourd'hui la plupart du
temps pour la présidentielle donc qui
enregistre quand même une abstention qui
augmente d'année en année depuis dix ans
mais beaucoup plus lentement et qui
continuent d'être une élection qui
mobilisent massivement oui mais c'est
dans le détail ce qui est intéressant de
voir c'est pour qui ces personnes qui ne
votent pas d'habitude et qui ne votent
que pour la présidentielle pour qui
votre tel parce que je me souviens d'une
d'études que vous aviez fait pour le
figaro avec opinionway c'était il ya
deux ans mais vous aviez conclu que plus
de trois français sur quatre étaient
favorables 1 vote contestataire dans
lequel vous inclus y est c'était soit
votre s'abstenir voter blanc ou voter
pour des candidats extrêmes comme moi je
cite la fondation fondapol jean luc
mélenchon nicolas dupont aignan où
marine le pen donc c'est aussi
intéressant de voir une fois qu'ils ne
vont aux urnes pour qu'ils votent ils
puisque quand on regarde trump qu'a
réussi à faire venir au sur des
abstentionnistes il a réussi mais ici
sont allés pour donald trump comme
l'avait fait encore une fois on va
croire que je obsessionnel mais en
italie le mouvement 5 étoiles donc ces
mouvements-là ont réussi à parler aux
app store est ce qu on a une réponse à
cette question tiens on va écouter
françois ruffin je fais signala régime
ce qui n'était pas forcément prévu à ce
moment de du débat donc on va écouter
françois ruffin tout de suite le député
la france insoumise delà de la somme il
était sur france culture c'est une
intervention qui date du mois d'avril
dernier en écoute françois russa je suis
pas sûr que l'abstention soit vécu comme
un adversaire par les dirigeants
politiques et je crois que par les
dirigeants il y avait un désir d'obtenir
l'apathie politique pour entraîner vers
ce qu'il y avait dans le traité
constitue l européen qui a été refusé
par le peuple qui a été acceptée par les
dirigeants de jeu je perçois pas ça
seulement on peut faire semblant
combattre l'abstention mais en vérité
elle arrange parce qu'il ya les jeunes
qui s'auto exclu mais il ya aussi les
classes populaires est ce que dominique
reynié on peut répondre à cette question
à qui profite l'abstention
d'abord ce que ce que vivent les femmes
vont me paraît juste il y a une forme d'
abstention et un certain niveau
d'abstention une distribution de
l'abstention qui peut tout à fait entrer
en résonance avec les intérêts de
majorité en place au dégoût verbard
s'est pas c'est une remarque que moi je
trouve tout à fait recevable donc ça
profite plus aux pouvoirs en place et à
dire que si vous avez des
abstentionnistes qui comme vous le
disiez son sens possiblement
des participants protestataires anti
système vous préférez les avoirs de
l'abstention vous faites votre deuil de
les convaincre et vous préférez les
avoir en dehors du jeu voilà ils ont eu
le sentiment de protester ou de dire je
m'en fiche je m'en occupe plus et vous
ne les avez pas pour peser sur un
scrutin parce que malgré tout pour
appeler ça ledit règlement électoral il
se mesure par abstention en effet mais
ces braconniers la spécialiste ici un
donc il se mesure en effet par la une
car en tendance à l'érosion de la
participation on se rappelle qu'en 2017
au second tour l'abstention et record
vraie envie 1969 c'est une action qui
n'a rien à voir dans cette maison on
peut le dire il n'y avait pas de grand
danger à voir l'un ou l'autre des deux
modérés on peut regarder l'évolution je
vous interromps prendra la parole de de
l'abstention effectivement aux
présidentielles on va regarder d'abord
au premier tour de la présidentielle
on est à 15 3% en 65 voilà on va voir la
courbe se
se matérialiser et un pic en 2000 de 28
4 % au premier tour de la présidentielle
avec les conséquences que l'on sait 16
2% en
2007 ça remonte à 22 ans lors de la
dernière élection et si on regarde ça
c'est le premier tour mais si on regarde
le second tour maintenant
na 15,7 en
1965 j'ai retenu les 12,7 en 74 16 % il
ya peu près la même participation en
2007 au premier ou au second tour et
puis on est on est encore à alors j'ai
pas le chiffre je suis pas sûr d'avoir
pris le monde
au
second tour de ce que j'avais noté 22 et
je savais que c'était pas le manche 6 0
25 à 25 au second tour il ya cinq ans
qu'est ce que ça dit dominique reynié
moi ce que je trouve d'important c'est
que d'une part en 2002 au premier tour
j'avais un record qui fabrique ce second
tour incroyable à l'époque
en 2017 au second tour alors que nous
avons déjà second tour incroyable si je
peux enfin vous êtes incroyables on va
s'habituer on a un niveau d'abstention
qui est record de même que puisque on
les comptabilise à part les bulletins
blancs qui explose littéralement c'est à
dire que vous avez les électeurs d'un
nombre significatif qui se déplacent moi
j'appelle ça une abstention civique je
me déplace je reste pas chez moi mais je
vote blanc il ya un truc que je dis je
sais pas très bien ce qui se dit pas ce
qu'on peut faire parler des votes blancs
mais enfin c'est très dispersé même si
on peut imaginer des convergences et là
je suis devant à la fois une situation
qui terme à terme et celle de 2002 au
second tour on s'en souvient le 5 mai
2002 nous avons un président chirac qui
réélu avec 60 % des inscrits
en 2017 à emmanuel macron est élu avec
43 % des inscrits donc derrière cette
érosion de la participation cette
participation dissidente de
protestataires on a aussi évidemment un
affaiblissement de la base de nos élus
et une fragilité magenta nation j'ai eu
pitié du du mandat présidentiel c'est à
dire que et d'ailleurs ça venait
régulièrement opposée par par d'autres
candidats ou par d'autres personnalités
politiques la fragilité de sa base sa
base électorale absolument alors que
pour le coup quand vous gagnez en plus
le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle à une énorme majorité ça
vous donne le sentiment que vous avez la
majorité du pays en plus avec vous et
donc ça vous fait démarrer en plus le
mandat avec le sentiment que globalement
bon bah vous avez 7 français sur 10 qui
a qui a qui ont voté pour nous et donc
vous avez une base effectivement aux
solides pour commencer à diriger le
chiffre qu'on oublie le plus vite c'est
celui de l'abstention tout norway et
puisque ce qu'a dit dominique seux le
chiffre des inscriptions 1,6 et ça qu'on
oublie et donc on s'arrête sur en gros à
la photographie que vous voyez sur les
chaînes d'info heureux ce soir du second
tour et donc par définition vous avez un
début de pouvoir et un début de mandat
qui vous donne effectivement le
sentiment que vous êtes tout puissant
parce que finalement vous avez une
grande majorité des français qui a voté
pour vous alors qu'effectivement et
c'était vraiment le cas pour le coup
pour emmanuel macron c'était absolument
pas le cas alors les six avaient regardé
comment les les politiques parler de
l'abstention je suis partie des
régionales un bien sûr parce que
certains massifs de l'abstention alors
emmanuel macron dit que c'est une alerte
démocratique et il appelle un comme
marine le pen comme tout le monde ils
ont eux appelé tous les abstentionnistes
en particulier les jeunes à aller aux
urnes à alesi marine le pen on s'en
souvient les avait carrément engueuler
mais le ton était vraiment très
surprenant emmanuel macron ans loos un
appel un peu plus solennel j'en appelle
tout particulièrement à notre jeunesse
qui ne peut laisser passer laisser les
autres décider à sa place et puis
finalement ils n'ont pas été du tout
entendu parce que le second tour a été
aussi calamiteux pourquoi parce que ces
abstentionnistes je pense que vous avez
le mot juste déjà sont inaudibles alors
comment savoir qu'ils sont s'ils ne
parlent pas comment les identifier
comment les capter comment les toucher
comment leur parler et c'est bien
l'enjeu pour tous les candidats jusqu'à
maintenant et puis les extrêmes sont
convaincus que de toute façon les
abstentionnistes sont dans leur camp
écoutez ce que disait jean luc mélenchon
c'était en août dans la drôme et marine
le pen sur france info au lendemain des
élections régionales nous avons tous été
victime de l'abstention vous place pour
bien vous avez raison nous plus que les
autres parce que structurellement notre
électorat est un électorat qui est déjà
abstentionnistes les jeunes 15 % des 18
35 ans 15 % seulement sont allés voter
et les classes populaires qui ne se sont
pas déplacés pour ces élections
intermédiaires je veux dire aux forts
effets de l'abstention est le pire qui
puisse nous arriver qu'un sondage dit de
la manière qui soit
fort
[Applaudissements]
oui et donc effectivement pour regarder
pour un peu dézoomer parce que parfois
ça nous permet de comprendre un peu
mieux la situation par exemple en
tunisie en 2019 l'élection
présidentielle qui est au même scrutin
que qu'en france ce matin celle direct
et avait deux candidats totalement
système à magnin des médias qui a quand
même fait la partie de la campagne en
prison est un prof de droit
constitutionnel de totalement inconnu
qui a fait le tour de la tunisie avec un
petit van est vraiment fonction est
alors l'abstention a totalement baissé
les taux de participation son record en
tunisie a plus prête je crois de mémoire
77% des tunisiens qui vont voter aux
deux tours est bon on connaît maintenant
des exemples étrangers oui bien sûr bat
donald trump a fait venir aux yeux des
abstentionnistes et puis encore une fois
effectivement le moment cinq étoiles en
italie je voudrais
c'est une braconniers rebondir sur ce
que disait la marine le pen ou ou jean
luc mélenchon est ce qu effectivement
l'abstentionnisme ils y feront ils
touchent d'abord où les plus présents
dans les classes populaires oui parce
que c'est très difficile d'analyser
politiquement l'abstention est de savoir
à qui profite l'abstention très
difficile surtout un depuis une dizaine
d'années que les frontières sociologique
des électorats sont beaucoup plus flou
en revanche on connaît les facteurs
déterminants de l'abstention des
facteurs sociodémographiques qui reste
très fort le premier facteur
l'abstention c'est l'âge c'est la
jeunesse et là j'ai sans doute aussi un
facteur générationnel qui s'est greffé
sur ce facteur là il ya 35 points
d'écart de participations entre les
25-29 ans et les 65 69 ans pour des
législatives en moyenne 35 points
d'écart c'est à dire que les jeunes qui
se mobilisent moins que les plus âgés
mais quand même massivement pour la
présidentielle cs de voter quelques
semaines ensuite pour les législatives
donc ce chiffre 85 % des 18-34 ans n'ont
pas voté aux régionales oui bien sûr
bien sûr tiges mais j'ai envie de dire
là le l'écart liées à l'âge était moins
fort aux dernières élections puisque le
taux d'abstention était tellement élevé
que ça affecta toutes les catégories y
compris les catégories d'âge donc il ya
le facteur âge qui est très très fort on
a un souci on n'arrive pas à faire voter
les jeunes au delà de l'élection
présidentielle de façon durable donc ça
doit interroger sur la manière notamment
dont on accompagne les premières
expériences avec un petit sursaut non il
ya eu 5 ans 10% où il faut arrêter de
considérer que les 50% d'abstention ou
une participation aux dernières
européennes qui étaient trois points
plus de participation que les
précédentes constitue voilà une victoire
non il ya eu un petit sursaut mais dans
un paysage marqué quand même globalement
par une presse par une faible
mobilisation ok elle facteur âge il ya
le facteur diplôme
dominique reynié l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure la politisation donc l'intérêt
pour la politique en grande partie
corrélée au niveau de diplôme et donc
plus vous êtes diplômé plus vous êtes
issus de milieux diplômés plus vous avez
de chances de vous intéresser à la
politique est d'aller voter et puis
enfin il ya le niveau de vie et la
catégorie socioprofessionnelle de façon
un peu global plus fragiles
économiquement plus vous restez à
l'écart des urnes et seule l'élection
présidentielle est capable de mobiliser
massivement encore aujourd'hui les
milieux les plus populaires et puis les
gens qui au quotidien sont complètement
éloigné de la politique alors on va
parler des solutions maintenant parce
que dans vos rapports respectifs
évidemment vous faites des des
propositions tiens on commence avec le
vote obligatoire une réaction celle du
président de la république c'était le 25
avril 2019 à l'issue du grand débat
je ne retiendrai pas cette option je ne
la retient dre pas pour deux raisons la
première c'est que je ne crois pas qu'on
répond à la crise démocratique par la
contrainte je ne crois pas que lorsqu'il
ya de la désaffection pour une élection
et du désintérêt on y répond en rendant
la chose obligatoire
on y répond en redonnant du sel à la vie
démocratique à cet égard la période que
nous vivons je le crois est une partie
de la solution
ensuite c'est qu'une fois qu'on a mis
l'obligation quand je regarde nos
voisins il est très dur de la faire
respecter
généralement elle n'est pas suivie est
ce qu'on met des amendes c'est très dur
alors certains proposent de priver leurs
droits civiques ceux qui ne vont pas
voter
c'est un peu étrange en tout cas ça
éloigne encore davantage du civisme et
de la vie politique ceux qui ne se
rendrait pas à cette obligation je n'y
crois pas le choix vous n'êtes pas
d'accord sur le vote obligatoire gerif
et si oui est favorable
enfin oui
maintenant j'y suis assez favorable
parce que effectivement et pour
reprendre ce que je disais au début
quand on voit effectivement l'état de
l'intérêt en fait pour la chose publique
l'état de l'intérêt pour la chose
démocratique fait je crois absolument
pas aux côtés on va avril enchanté la
politique fait j'ai l'impression que ça
a fait honnêtement j'ai 30 ans ça fait
quinze ans que j'entends on va ré
enchanter la politique va vous redonner
goût à la politique on va vous redonner
goût au débat public ce qu'on entend à
chaque fois entre les deux tours de
l'élection c'est à mais sans doute que
nous n'avons fait pas assez de pédagogie
je regardais les médias les médias
faisaient leur autocritique entre les
deux tours de l'élection régionale et
départementale en disant peut-être que
nous n'avons pas assez de pédagogie etc
mais ils n'ont fait que de parler de ça
claude parler de ça que de parler de ça
en permanence ya vu une overdose d'infos
sur le sujet et vous l'avez très bien
dit lui aucun sursaut entre les détours
alors que pour le coup les appels au
civisme les tribunes de remobiliser vous
etc etc on en a à gogo depuis maintenant
dix ou vingt ans donc je pense qu'en
fait ce ressort là il ne fonctionne pas
et effectivement au même titre que le
disais pour obliger les gens pour pour
faire en sorte que les gens se fassent
vacciner on fallait quasiment rendre le
vaccin effectivement obligatoire en tout
cas en faire une contrainte pour accéder
à un certain nombre de choses moi
effectivement je pense que rendre un
moment donné le vote obligatoire n'est
pas une mauvaise idée avec évidemment
deux éléments premiers éléments il faut
mettre le vote blanc tu comme suffrages
exprimés en contrepartie effectivement
de ce vote obligatoire ça pose pas mal
de sujets je pense que dominique on
parlera est évidemment si on rentre dans
ce débat-là de mettre en place le vote
obligatoire il faut avoir un climat dans
le pays assez apaisés assez serein il
faut pas le faire à n'importe quel
moment il faut pas le faire juste avant
une élection présidentielle il faut pas
le faire dans un climat de crise comme
on a pu le vivre pendant liégeois donc
faut bien choisir son moment mais bon à
mon sens en tout cas je pense que c'est
une des rares une des seules façons de
réa culture et les gens à la chose
démocratique à la chose publique
sûrement pas maintenant mais peut-être
justement à l'élection présidentielle
dernier craignait jeu moi je pense que
c'est fait et dit parle le président a
fait valoir des arguments qui sont je
trouve dirimant
il ya quelque chose de gênant dans
l'obligation qui est ce la remarque moi
sans que je m'appuie qui est de faire
peser la responsabilité sur les
électeurs à dire que vous n'y allez pas
donc on va vous y contraindre c'est
quand même mal démarré la chose
on ne sait pas on ne sait pas comment
faire pour contrer non vraiment les
différentes strates et on préfère
impasse civic si on imaginer quelque
chose vraiment contraignant qui jouerait
sur cette dimension consumériste
individualiste mais c'est en réalité
[Musique]
comment dirais je ne veux rien réparer
du tout dans ce qui se passe quoi et si
vous n'avez pas vous ne pouvez pas aller
au restaurant
sérieusement moi je pense par exemple
aux quotas à la question des quotas par
exemple les quotas de femmes dans les
conseils d'administration ou dans les
comités de direction des entreprises est
ce qu'à un moment il faut pas que la loi
le règlement quand là quand la société
ne prend pas une direction il faut pas
un peu lui forcer la main c'est à dire
est donc grande le vote est obligatoire
il faut rendre aux urnes
non je suis pas du tout je suis pas
favorable ça présente l'intérêt le vote
obligatoire de contraindre les candidats
à s'adresser à tout le monde donc en ça
c'est intéressant mais mais on est dans
une société qui n'a pas encore
expérimenté tous les moyens possibles
pour faire revenir les gens vers les
urnes de façon moins contraignante on a
vu que l'injonction à participer ça
fonctionnait pas encore moins auprès des
jeunes qui justement considère
aujourd'hui très largement que le vote
est un droit et pas avant tout un devoir
donc quand ils ne comprennent pas les
enjeux quand il ne n'identifie pas les
candidats il ne se déplace pas ils
assument de ne pas se déplacer alors que
les personnes âgées continuent de se
déplacer alors même qu'elle n'y croient
pas forcément toujours non plus donc ça
produit du vote désinvesti désenchanté
qui est pas plus réjouissant que
l'abstention en réalité il ya plein de
choses à faire à commencer par regarder
du côté de la jeunesse et se poser la
question de savoir comment on crée de la
citoyenneté au fond m'offrir une seconde
aujourd'hui
fanta qui est juste là au 03 instant
quand je vais d'abord donné la parole à
anne hidalgo puisque c'est l'une des
propositions la candidate socialiste le
droit de vote à 16 ans
pour faire davantage participer les
citoyens le prochain gouvernement social
démocrate d'allemagne propose d'abaisser
l'âge du vote à 16 ans nous le ferons
france
qu'est ce qui justifie encore d'exclure
de la vie démocratique
ceux qui sont les plus concernés par des
décisions prises aujourd'hui mais qui
pèseront demain nous le ferons et donc
quand un calme et je suis heureux de
voir ça c'était une question ce débat
autour du ou autre pour le vote à 16 ans
qui s'invite au sénat dans quelques
jours exactement ce sera examiné en
séance le 9 décembre prochain et s'est
porté au sénat donc par le groupe
socialiste on comprend la mesure
principale contenues dans l'article 1 de
la proposition de loi c'est le passage
de 18 ans à 16 ans pour voter et ce dès
2022 en texte alors cela concernerait
tout de suite un million cinq cent mille
jeunes d'après martine filleul la
sénatrice ps à l'origine du texte libre
et c'est à dire que et bien un jeune de
16 ans il peut être salarié il peut
faire de la conduite accompagnée il peut
passer son bafa alors pourquoi pas voter
et après avoir discuté des associés avec
les associations de jeunes et les
chercheurs comme par exemple anne muxel
qui est une chercheuse au cnrs qui porte
cette idée eh bien ces sénateurs ps ils
ont la conviction que plus on apprend à
voter tôt plus on vote est bien plus on
est un électeur fidèles le droit de vote
s'accompagnerait d'autres mesures
écoutez le chef de file de ce sénateur
socialiste au sénat ancien ministre de
la jeunesse de françois hollande c'est
patrick kenner l'assaut sur les jeunes
et les dramatiques aujourd'hui il y a
trois quarts des jeunes qui sont
abstenus aux dernières élections
départementales et régionales trois
quarts est ce qu'on peut se dire bain
puisqu'il ya trois cas d'abstention les
jeunes donc pas de vote à 16 ans non au
contraire plus les jeunes votent
rapidement précocément avec un
accompagnement effectivement de
citoyenneté est bien plus on en fera des
citoyens sur le long terme alors on
comprend ya la mesure d'âge mais non
qu'est aussi un accompagnement dans ce
texte qui est proposé par les
socialistes regarder parmi les autres
mesures du texte on voit l'enseignement
obligatoire des sciences politiques dès
le collège une meilleure formation des
enseignants également et aussi à la
création de conseils de jeunes dans
toutes les communes de plus de 5000
habitants on suivra donc cet examen en
séance c'est jeudi prochain mais déjà je
peux vous dire que le texte a très peu
de chances d'être adopté la droite n'est
pas favorable en plus c'est une
proposition de loi donc il faut deux
lectures par chambre donc d'ici la fin
du quinquennat c'est bien possible merci
pour ces pour ces détails c'est une
braconniers je retiens ça plus on
apprend à voter tous plus ont voté plus
on est à mes lecteurs fidèles c'est vrai
si oui il ya des très beaux travaux
américains notamment qu'il le montre
si on parvient à faire voter deux jeunes
gens en trois pour 3 scrutin d'affilée
ont créé une habitude de vote et on
estime aujourd'hui que l'habitude de
vote explique ray environ un tiers de la
participation électorale donc en
accompagnant mieux les premières
expériences de vote on se donne les
moyens de recréer delà de la deûle afin
de remobiliser sur sur du long terme
notamment par la création d'une habitude
et ça ça passe forcément par un travail
autour de l'école pas forcément par les
enseignants mais autour de l'école et
l'avantagent d'abaisser le vote à 16 ans
il n'est pas un abaissement de l'âge
parce que c'est vrai que ça paraît
paradoxal les jeunes de 18 ans à 29 ans
s'abstiennent terriblement donc on se
demande si on va pas mécaniquement
augmenter l'abstention en abaissant
l'âge électoral donc ça n'aurait de sens
cette mesure là que si on accompagne à
l'école notamment les premières
expériences et si on repense ce que doit
être l'éducation morale et civique qui
est aujourd'hui à la fois pas vraiment
mis en oeuvre et en même temps
extrêmement théorique quand elle l'oeil
les enseignants ne sont pas formés ils
sont très réticents à aÿ initié en fait
les jeunes au à la compréhension des
institutions qui est pourtant absolument
nécessaire pour commencer à s'intéresser
à la démocratie représentative et aux
institutions et soudan penser l'un et
l'autre le droit de vote à 16 ans j'ai
réveillé ma non je suis assez d'accord
effectivement si une braconniers l'a
très bien dit il ya très bons travaux
pour montrer plus voter tôt
effectivement plus vous êtes à culture
partie de vos propositions non non ça
fait pas partie de provisions je trouve
que par contre ça pose un autre débat
parce qu'un petit j'ai pas d'avis sur le
droit de vote à 16 ans mais par
définition ça pose le débat de l'âge de
la majorité parce que par définition si
vous autorisez des gens à voter à 16 ans
il faut attendre 18 ans avant de se
porter par exemple candidat à une
élection
ça veut dire qu'en gros vous avez la
voir une cohorte d'individus qui n'a pas
l'âge d'être potentiellement candidat à
des élections c'est à partir de 18h que
vous pouvez être candidat dans une
municipalité nous un conseil
départemental dans un conseil régional
que sais-je encore donc vous faites
voter des gens qui par définition n'ont
pas la responsabilité d'être demain dans
des assemblées et donc il faut attendre
deux ans pour être élu donc à mon sens
sans dire non mais à mon sens sa fausse
agression de si vous autorisez le vote à
16 ans ça peut la question de baisser en
fait la majorité d'une façon générale
pour l'ensemble des espaces et sur
l'ensemble de l'espace public dans ce
pays est ce qu'un peu d'arrière pensées
politiques de la part des socialistes
même si le canton d'uzès a donc aucune
chance de passer parce que voilà ce
jeune public voterai plus plus à gauche
est bon tout autour c'est parce que
c'est une idée de progrès de
d'émancipation de confiance enfin ce
sont des valeurs qui peuvent dans
lesquelles un parti peut se retrouver
moi j'y suis favorable lors sans vous
dire que c'est la réponse à tous les
atouts des problèmes mais je trouve que
c'est une belle idée c'est une marque de
confiance que c'est prendre au sérieux
les nouvelles générations de leur dire
écoutez alesi et j'entends les arguments
de gier ce que je conçois tout à fait et
je me disais en écoutant au fond on
pourrait presque tunisie à l'envers
c'est à dire qu' on aurait une forme de
propédeutique on pourrait qu'on peut
dire aux citoyens on vous donne d'abord
droit de voter faux ce sera votre
premier droit à une certaine
l'apprentissage en quelques certaines
valorisations vous allez avoir ça
d'abord puis ensuite vous accéderez à
l'éligibilité ça peut s'expliquer aussi
comme ça et en tout cas il me semble
c'est une belle idée de dire vous n'êtes
pas assez nombreux à voter on va faire
un tri plus demandant le corps électoral
il ya quelque chose de volontaire et
optimiste là dedans alors ne pas parmi
vos propositions vos idées qu est ce que
vous mettez en avant qu est ce qu il
faudrait faire prioritairement pour pour
redonner aux français le goût de
l'élection le mot des urnes je commence
à y penser alors le goût d'élections ça
dépend des candidats aide politique par
définition une voix des candidats qui
parviennent à incarner des projets de
société et qui
donc qu'ils savent qu'ils font un peu de
pédagogie
et qui font rêver
bien évidemment aucune solution
technique ne ramènera massivement les
électeurs vers les urnes en revanche en
revanche comme l'abstention est
multifactorielle quelques points de
participation gagné au regard de la
situation c'est pas négligeable et par
des mesures techniques on peut faciliter
la participation et moi ma dont c'était
le mot de sa correspondance bien sûr il
y en a un problème énorme c'est comment
si
on a un problème énorme avec une
procédure d'inscription électorale qui a
hérité du passé qui est complètement
inadaptée à une société de la mobilité
obliger les gens à se déplacer ou à
penser plusieurs semaines avant le vote
à se réinscrire et enfin à une étape
préalable qui n'est pas comprise ça
laisse à l'écart du volte une partie
importante de la population en 2017 pour
la présidentielle on avait 7 millions
six cent mille personnes qui n'étaient
pas inscrits au bon endroit sur les
listes électorales en plus des 5
millions de non inscrits
ces personnes là elles sont
majoritairement jeunes
l'intention de la jeunesse explique en
partie par l'ama l'inscription de la
jeunesse en 2010 7 43% des 25 29 ans 43
% n'étaient pas inscrits au bon endroit
ça veut dire que pour voter il doit
franchir une distance qui peut être
vraiment dissuasif quand on n'est pas
politisé alors que la dominique reynié
ont un mot là dessus puis ensuite vous
me direz ce que vous prenez
prioritairement mais on peut considérer
que les outils numériques pourrait
simplifier l'inscription au passé pas
très compliqué là où il faut faire
attention les sens et c'est sans doute
une ressource oui mais en matière
électorale comme dans ces domaines ils
sont extraordinairement sensible il faut
être sûr que
parce road on est capable de sécuriser
bien sûr papa du vote numérique 1 je
crois que j'ai bien compris de façon
générale il faut un peu un peu bidouillé
des listes électorales point de vue on
peut mettre tout ce système là donc là
il faut voir les experts là dessus mais
moi je suis convaincu aussi que
il ya des mesures techniques même si
hélas mal inscrits psion est un sujet
majeur
ça fait un morceau du chemin et puis
après je vais faire une réponse un peu
large mais je vais dans laquelle je
crois beaucoup je pense qu'il faut
reconnaître les scrutins à leur juste
valeur et je vais prendre pour être
symétrique le référendum de 2005
qui avait donné le sentiment très
profond l'entend souvent ça que ce
qu'une fois que les françaises sont
décidés au fond ça n'a pas eu vraiment
des faits alors c'est excessif de dire
comme ça en réalité mais c'est une
perception qui a duré et je prenais un
autre exemple qui est le référendum
décidé pour notre dame des landes qui
était en faveur de l'aéroport qui nous
ravit qui ne sera pas finalement
construit ça ce sont des gestes
extraordinairement coûteux pour la
validité du suffrage et puis ma réponse
très générale serait de dire que je
reconnais que c'est un peu un peu large
mais la démonstration de l'efficacité de
l'action publique est une façon
d'alimenter le sens du vote l'idée
d'aller voter et après il ne se passe
rien et très répandue dont il ya le ya
le respect de l'institution qui est
quand même très répandu mais il faut le
nourrir quand même d'une efficacité pour
que la souveraineté se ressentent à
travers le vote c'est intéressant ni
l'un ni l'autre vous avez parlé de la
proportionnelle je sais pas si si c'est
ce qui vous vient comme comme
proposition comme solution non non c'est
moi j'en parle
alors déjà un élément sur lequel je suis
assez sceptique c'est le vote par
correspondance
parce que par définition le vote il ya
la dimension isoloirs qu'à la dimension
liberté de conscience il ya le lieu
c'est un des rares lieux en fait
l'isoloir où vous pouvez choisir en
votre âme et conscience et en conservant
ce secret peut-être jusqu'à la fin de
vos jours j'aimerais cérémonial
absolument et en plus il ya le rite
effectivement il ya le cérémonial est
par définition vote par correspondance
votre chez soi que ce soit par courrier
ou que ce soit par les parts par voie
électronique vous avez quelqu'un
derrière vous ne peux vous dire pour qui
voter vous avez une soeur un frère une
communauté ou que sais-je encore et pour
le coup je pense qu'il faut conserver la
dimension isoloirs et aux libertés de
conscience que permet à l isoloir contre
moi une proposition que j'aime bien et
je sais qu on en débattra sans doute
c'est le vote par son par anticipation
serge suis totalement d'accord ici d'une
braconniers sur l'air de mobilité dans
lequel on est à l'ère du bougisme en
permanence dans lequel on est l'associé
du sur mesure dans la suite du sur
mesure obliger les gens à ne voter que
le dimanche de 8 heures à 20 heures je
pense que c'est un problème alors que si
demain par exemple dans une grande ville
vous permettez aux gens ban de volée
redit lundi partira le mardi le mercredi
le jeudi le vendredi dans plusieurs fois
utilisée aux états unis vont absolument
en avant l'avant le dans les dates
annoncées dans les plus petites villes
vous pouvez vous dire bon on n'ouvre que
le vendredi et le samedi et le dimanche
je sais que ça posera un sujet qui est
s'il se passe quelque chose dans la
semaine bon vous pouvez peut-être avoir
le sentiment que votre vote absolument
mais alors il nous reste deux minutes ça
passerait de la proportionnelle vous en
parlez pas aux législatives par exemple
de proportionnelle
moi je pense c'est une fausse idée à ce
sujet vous savez que la callas
proportionnelle vous moi je fais j'ai
fait exprès récemment j'ai interrogé un
échantillon là dessus vous demandez la
proportionnelle où le scrutin
majoritaire les gens sont
proportionnelles puis vous reposer la
question en expliquant comment ça marche
là les gens sont contre enfin andy
comprennent qu'ils vont pas choisir en
fait du tout les élus quasiment pas pas
les élus donc avec le système sur le
liste leur ardeur se refroidit et je ne
crois pas l'idée qu'il n'ya pas
suffisamment de choix et que c'est ça
qui expliquerai vous regardez en 2002
vous le montrions n'avait l'abstention
qui explose de 28% il ya seize candidats
à la présidentielle nationale à bout
c'est vrai bon bah voilà samedi dernier
mot non non j'ai juste mais en un mot
vous êtes sûr qu' il n'y a pas de crise
de la démocratie représentative c'est ce
que vous avez dit
en commençant cette émission on pensait
pas que la défiance envers les
politiques et des passants second des
trois courses ici
jamais dit qu'il ait pas de crise
démocratie représentative je pense que
l'abstention rencontre d'une distance
aux urnes qui est problématique qui
interroge la vie s'organise à côté y
compris les collectif s'organise à côté
des institutions et ça ça doit nous
interroger bien entendu merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat c'était c'était passionnant je
vais au site et vos livres les inaudible
c'est le dernier paru avec nos bailleurs
7 aux presses de sciences po julie
pelletier la fête est finie ces deux
éditions de l'observatoire dominique
reynié renvoie ce cette dernière
parution de la fondapol 2022 le risque
populiste en france sur l'accident on
peut en changer et ben voilà le message
est passé et lætitia accrue pas il ya
évidemment votre livre la tentation du
clown aux éditions
buchet chastel ces sages avaient bien le
nom de l'éditeur en tête merci